welcome to today's exploration into the
world of technical Su where we unravel
the Ines of optimizing your website for
search engines in this video we will
delve into the fundamental aspects of
techical SEO understand the concepts
such as crawling indexing and the
critical link between them discover why
optimizing your site from a technical
standpoint is Paramount in the digital
landscape and gain insights into the SE
best practices that can elevate your
online presence but before we move on
with the topics make sure to subscribe
to our YouTube channel and press the
Bell icon to never miss an update from
Simply learn now without further Ado
let's get started with the first topic
that is what is technical SEO so
technical SEO is like making sure your
website is easy for search engines like
Google to read and understand just like
You' organize a book with chap adapters
and a table of contents to make it
easier to navigate technical SEO
involves organizing your website so that
search engines can easily find and show
your web pages to people searching for
information this includes making your
website load quickly fixing any errors
that might prevent search engines from
reading your site using special tags to
highlight important information and
making sure your website works well on
mobile devices all of these things help
your website show up higher in the
search results and make it easier for
people to find what they are looking for
site speed is also crucial in this just
as people prefer fast loading websites
search engine prioritize websites that
load quickly fixing crawl errors is like
repairing broken links in a book it
ensures that search engines can access
and understand all the content on your
website without any hiccups now just a
quick info for you if you you want to
upskill yourself master digital
marketing skills and land your dream job
or grow in your career then you must
explore simply learn cohort of various
digital marketing programs simply R
offers various certifications and
postgraduate programs in collaboration
with some of the world's leading
universities like SPG Purdue and meta
through our courses you will gain
knowledge and work ready expertise in
skills like search engine marketing
strategies for paid campaigns analytics
Roi and evaluation and over a dozen of
others
that's not all you'll also get the
opportunity to work on multiple projects
and learn from industry experts working
in Top Tire product companies and
academian from top universities after
completing these courses thousands of
Learners have transitioned into digital
marketing role as a fresher or moved on
to a higher paying job role and profile
if you're passionate about making your
career in this field then make sure to
check out the link in the pin comments
and description box to find a digital
marketing program that fits your
experience and areas of Interest trust
all right now let's understand why
should you optimize your site so let's
have a look at the first reason which is
improved search engine ranking search
engines reward well optimized websites
with higher rankings technical SE ures
that search engines can easily
understand and navigate your site
contributing to better visibility and
ranking next is enhanced user experience
technical SEO is not just about pleasing
search engines it also improves the user
experience fast loading ages mobile
responsiveness and secure connections
all contribute to positive user
experience which can impact your site's
bounce rate and overal engagement the
next is competitive Advantage as the
digital landscape becomes increasingly
competitive technical optimization can
provide a distinct Advantage websites
that load quickly are mobile friendly
and have secure connections are more
likely to attract and retain Visitors by
doing these you can attract more organic
traffic enhance user engagement and
ultimately achieve your online goals
more effectively now coming to the next
part which is key metrics so there are
several key metrics that website owners
should track to ensure their pages are
optimized these include site speed
mobile friendliness crawl errors index
coverage structure data implementation
and overall website Health monitoring
these metrics allows for identification
of potential issues and the
implementation of necessary improvements
to maintain an optimized website all all
right so this was about key metrics now
let's move on to the next topic which is
crawling so crawling is a process by
which search engine bards that is also
known as spiders or crawlers navigate
the web discovering and collecting
information from websites the efficiency
of crawling directly influences how well
search engines can index and rank a site
when a search engine bought visits a
website it follows links from one page
to another collecting information about
each page it encounters though the
technical SEO website owners can ensure
that their site is easily crawlable by
search engine Bots this involves
creating a clear site structure
optimizing internal linking and
utilizing tools such as robots.txt and
XML site maps to guide crawlers through
the site efficiently next is indexing
indexing is the process by which search
engines organize and Store The
information collected during crawling
it's like the search engine's way of
creating a detailed catalog of all the
web pages it has form a well index sites
ensures that search engines can quickly
retrieve and display relevant
information to users when they enter a
search query this process is crucial for
ensuring that the right web pages are
shown to users when they search for
specific topics or keywords all right
now this was about indexing now let's
understand about calling an
indexing all right so understanding
crawling and indexing so before search
engines can answer a search quer they
first go through the calling process to
find publicly available web pages to add
to their Index this is like their way of
discovering and collecting information
from all over the Internet during The
Crawling process search engines Bots
follow links from one page to another
discovering new content and updating
their index with the latest information
available on the web once the crawling
is done the search engine organizes
sorts and stores the information to find
it in the database which is is called
the index this index is like a huge
library of web pages and it's what the
search engine uses to quickly find the
right information when someone searches
for something during The Crawling
process search engine bards also pay
attention to the instructions provided
in the robots.txt file which tells them
which page they are allowed to crawl and
index on a website additionally web
Masters can use a no index tag in the
HTML code of a web web page to instruct
search engine boards not to include that
particular page in their Index this
allows website owners to control which
pages are made available to users
through search engine results these
mechanisms help website owners manage
how their content is discovered and
index by surge engines all right so this
was about crawling and indexing now now
let's move on to the next topic which is
technical SEO best practices so first
one on the list is on page optimization
so optimize your website on web page
elements such as title tags meta
descriptions headings and image alt text
to make it easier for search engines to
understand the content of your web pages
so second thing that is the second
practice for technical Su that you can
do is mobile friendliness ensure that
your website is optimized for mobile
devices as mobile friendliness is now a
crucial ranking factor for search
engines so this is another important
factor now the third practice that we
can do for technical SEO is speed so
improve your websites loading speed as
faster loading Pages tend to rank higher
in search results and provide a better
user experience the next is link
building so acquiring high quality back
links from reputable websites to improve
your sit's Authority and credibility in
the eyes of search engs this also works
in many cases all right
now fifth is analytics and monitoring
using tools like Google analytics to
track your website's performance monitor
keyword rankings and identifying areas
of for improvement so this is another
practice for technical SEO now sixth one
is fix broken pages so identify and fix
any broken links or pages on a website
broken links can negatively impact user
experience and search engine rankings
regularly check for broken pages and
ensure that they are directed or fixed
promptly next is duplicate content isues
avoiding having a duplicate content on
your website as it can confuse searge
engines and impact your sites ranking
ensure that each page on your site
offers unique and valuable content use
canonical tags to indicate the preferred
version of similar content and address
any duplicate content tissues all right
so excluding these duplicate content to
shoes is also a very important factor
and it improves your SEO and site
visibility so as we conclude our journey
through technical SEO we have uncovered
the vital components that shape your
website's visibility in search engine
results from the significance of
optimizing your site through the
mechanics of crawling and indexing
understanding these elements is key to a
robust online presence armed with
insights and best practices you are now
better equipped to navigate the dynamic
landscape of technical SE ensuring your
websites not only meets but exceeds the
expectations of both users and search
engines Alik all right guys with that we
have come to the end of this video If
you like this video please give it a
thumbs up I hope it really helped you
all thanks for watching stay safe and
keep learning staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upscaling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here